[Musique]
à paris c'est bien c'est mon fait plus
rien tellement elle a passé un mois
alors moi j'en lui on a une question de
talent il exactement
on a une belle question mais j'espère
aller toujours des questions alors si
c'est pour faire plaisir à ce serait une
belle que ça y est c'est parti on y va
bonjour je m'appelle hélène quand je
vois à votre équipe je me pose une
question quelles qualités faut-il avoir
pour être chroniqueur dans votre
émission et surtout faut-il vraiment
avoir des qualités
excellente question à mme hélène et bien
sûr qu'il faut avoir des qualités
déjà il faut avoir une bonne maîtrise de
ses nerfs comme isabelle morini bosc à
isoler ce formidable célèbres ont jamais
même quand on critique ces lancements
regarder la tête du chien dans la
chronique qu'on va revoir qui était pas
honorable dans la même chronique de
camille j'adore cette séquence tu peux
faire un lancement clair n'en fut rien
ouais les gars
elle s'appelle la douceur si savard
complimenter ses collègues comme ici
regardez caroline ithurbide qui parle
aux français pour vous tous la table moi
je suis impressionné par le nombre de
mots de vocabulaire disent ah ah oui
c'est qu'elle les oublie pas non mais on
va fait impressionnante et le moins bien
je suis désolé mais ça tombe sur belge a
fait 3e comme toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous dire c'était pas sa semaine à
benjamin on sortait agacé ce qui est
bien que les gars c'est benjamin c qui
marmonne dans son coin
oui devient très ironiques comme qu'il
en avait c'est que notre expert médias
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez luc
adorable ouais je vous rappelle les
journalistes à nulle part d'experts mis
date de naissance ou encore lucas droits
tv génial ah oui c'est ça on s'en bat
benjamin un bon il y aura bien fait
fermer sa bouche les extraits de la
semaine agacé de benjamin
enfin rangé les décorations du sapin de
noël pour merde quoi
ouais non non on en mars mais oui moi je
le range toujours j'avais rangé les
sapins de noël à bois sentais vraiment
le sapin de ma classe j'ai fini par le
jeter j'aime bien le fait que je sois
allé jusqu'au bout du truc et que tu me
racontes la petite conversation privée
merci kiryat gat très important que le
dessin ça fait quelque chose
agathe n'est pas très bonne a fort
justement ces scellés
[Applaudissements]
alors pour être un chroniqueur il faut
aussi être gentil et que ses camarades
bon et nora est un problème fait ce
qu'il peut mais même quand elle va être
sympa elle a toujours une formulation de
phrases un peu malheureuse
là par exemple elle voulait prendre soin
de catherine laborde en s'excusant de
dire des grossièretés et au passage de
les voir elle va aussi lui rappeler son
âge
non
six mondes des romans à côté
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
qu'elle était loin je précise quand même
qu'on n'était pas en train de son filet
puisque l'on rigole de nouri maquillage
préfère lui jaoui stratégie bipe
oui mais c'est les séries
jean-luc à quoi qu'il arrive dans un
instant on n'y a pas de choses dont le
retour du bistrot aussi plein de
révélations et tout ce que n'a pas voulu
voir s'il ya des révélations notamment
sur la nouvelle je crois sur radio
agathe est fourni énormément
oui ça va plaire à jean michel émond
jean-luc on est dans les quatre tiers
alors on est bien on continue
alors je 2 on faisait question qu'est ce
que je suis ce qu'était un nom je veux
pas que vous décidiez mais non c'est la
chute de shy'm est ce qu est un bon
chroniqueur et vos chroniqueurs c'est
aussi un chroniqueur qui s'imposent oui
et dans cette catégorie agathe elle est
parfaite ouais maintenant a carrément
elle dit ce qui est drôle ou pas dans
l'émission à la police de laval vous
allez voir jean michel est complètement
sous son emprise
le canard de la semaine c'est penser un
petit peu un enfant qui aurait quitté
son papa vous et sa maman s'est vite un
peu trop vite à vous êtes vous croyez
que je gagne 6,8 en fait
[Rires]
le mec est pas bien maîtresse agatha par
les uns
alors quoi être un bon chroniqueur il
faut aussi savoir faire plaisir à civile
et donc avalé un car ça va pas
lancement à vous faire une révélation ce
soir beaucoup de gens mal intentionnés
disent que cyril maltraite ses
chroniqueurs c'est faux au contraire
quand ils font une bonne émission pour
dans la pub ils les récompenses avec de
la nourriture
[Musique]
aux arrêts
donner à ma dernière
et
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
chercher tout ça j'ai quand même attendu
une blogueuse non ccc mathieu qui a dit
c'est une goutte 2a d'accord merci par
les pays bas 2 parce qu'il n'y avait il
y avait comme une nuit avec vous à
gagner ça ne l'a pas mis dedans oui
c'est vrai oui c'est vrai je rester
correct pas tous eu la bouche ouverte
ah ouais ben oui moi je préfère et que
vous l'avez fait que jean-michel c'était
sont bien venus participer au concours
oui cinq avaient nui à gagner avec moi
d'ailleurs personne n'a pour l'instant
gelé parce qu'ils avaient gagné magatte
diop c'est un bas taux depuis les
parties et jean-michel alors posé la
question mais que prend cyril pour avoir
cette énergie et ses idées tout est ce
que c'est un produit autorisé bas soir
je vais vous dire aussi la vérité
pendant les pubs séries tu prends bien
quelque chose je vous préviens c'est
très surprenant car y'a que sur l'icis a
fait cet effet là
[Musique]
l'offre de jeu
[Applaudissements]
du bien l'a dirigée par un gain de 2
qu'il y ait de l'eau de l'homme et à une
heure j'adore relance et s'assurer que
la tuerie là avec javier merci bon
heureusement dans l'équipe et il tombe
pas tous à l'eau alors je me suis dit
que pour leur rendre hommage
c'était le moment ou jamais de les
renvoyer au bistro saq connaissez le
principe ont ralenti les images on a
l'impression que tout le monde est
bourré bas c'est un peu les pour la
pression
[Musique]
y a là rien peut-être chalet dernier
dans la rue tu crois mais non juste
peut-être
qu'est ce qui t'a s'embêter autant le à
deux ou trois troncs n'est pas candidat
il faut souhaiter la venue miers un
grand délire pas candidat
et
et vous qu'est ce qu'elle fout en quarts
à dubaï à mesure vers ce jeu j'ai cru
bien sûr c'est un fake et la jeune
tchèque tu m'as dit qu acheter oui mais
je crois toujours en colère et qu'est ce
que la phrase exacte c'est quoi pour
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la promise et je n'ai pas les paroles
c'est remarquable
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
sur ce que j'écrive à l ère de l écrit
zob il est venu trop miami excusez moi
je retraduire c'est mon cas nos
séminaires thor est majeur
une raison simple la troisième équipe
c'est qu'avant ce qu'ils voient ce qui
me passionne plus écrasé les épreuves et
mala maintenant au lieu que muffat qui à
20 qui a gagné ça s'arrête
malam at on l'attend le deuxième savoir
qui sera une dernier donc ça ça rallonge
des épreuves est debout ça rajoute
s'agit là d'une idée ni une île à nice
la barre pour oublier ça pour se
remettre le moment tp et même maintenant
touche pas à ma mignonneries baisse les
tarifs aussi d'aider des enfants était
joué mon rôle c'est vrai il y avait un
mini jean-mi un mini gilles à midi titi
et c'est un magnifique moment car pour
tous ces enfants c'est un rêve de
rencontrer leurs idoles comme ici la
mini capucines
la vérité le ministre lui qui me
connaissait pas non plus un la mine et
n'aura elle ne connaissait même pas le
prénom de ces cas était censée
représenter mais pas grave car la mini
morini-bosc va lui donner tous les mots
nécessaires pour que l'illusion soit
parfaite
j'aimerais qu'on s'aperçoit que pour les
enfants enora à trois mois de
vocabulaire en tout et pour tout
[Musique]
dussault
mais le ministre dit que vous avez
préféré c'est agathe exception comprend
pourquoi parce que c'est un phénomène
vous allez voir la conversation entre
mini agathe et munich a pu comment à la
fois elle va s'imposer en force et le
son comme la version adulte
je
albert ii
j'ai pas encore parlé des qualités de
matthieu delormeau pour être un bon
chroniqueur et bien tout simplement
parce que quand il s'agit de d'énumérer
ses qualités celui qui en parle le mieux
c'est lui est ce son rôle par rapport à
gilles isabelle ou baguette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien non
moi doit fuir et le divertissement
l'intelligence la culture donné le la
aux débats
les méchas celle-ci d'ordonner le dos
des marais
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai qu'il a bien donné le dos aux
débats oui au niveau de la mer donné
leur ai aussi
[Rires]
le vent du mois maintenant vont avoir du
trimestre voire de l'année la syrie
s'est surpassé je crois que c'est dans
mon top 5 des ventes mais depuis la
création touche pas à mon poste il est
magistral qui on recevait le pauvre
jarry non 6
hélas
je ne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
regardez regardez
j'arrive jarry qu'on a piégé dans la
grande rade bas demain vous verrez et on
va démarrer d'ailleurs avec jari vous
paierez c'est fou voilà et encore une
fois je j'aime ce mec c'est c'est un
génie il est très drôle et là c'est que
ça m'a fait mal de voir ça je sais bien
parce que je n'ai pas vu du tout le
pauvre alors un autre problème de tpm pc
c'est que dès que vous mettez une
pancarte vierge devant le chroniqueur
est sans objet de dessiner un zizi oui
c'est vrai c'est plus fort que lui ce
qui donne des dialogues surréalistes et
des situations assez gênante surtout
quand on reçoit des politiques la gâteau
proulx avait dessiné le p'tit bazar de
jean michel maire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aucun doute
[Musique]
delaunay
peut pas travailler comme ça je sais pas
s'il va recevoir d'autres politiques
parlent en tout cas c'est une très bonne
transition pour aborder tout ce qu'on
n'aurait pas voulu voir et entendre dans
l'émission et on commence par la
présentation de l'expert média préféré
de benjamin castaldi
le cadeau râble est exceptionnel il a
une communauté incroyable c'est notre
expert médias le vendredi on aime faut
regarder on dirait brad pitt dans
légendes d'automne c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
c
je
le syncass karaté
[Applaudissements]
rassuré mes chansons
cette jambe
[Musique]
guy
non
la légitimité d'un homme ou d'une femme
qui aspire à devenir président de la
république je dois twitté je traite pas
amer oscars instagram facebook
non je ne fais pas moi même j'en ai
tellement faire qu'à leur allez-vous
jackie et michel
les frères
[Musique]
au début c'est le tour de france
jean-luc mercier